on est au milieu du marathon budgétaire
il reste encore des centaines
d'amendements à examiner dans la partie
1 qu'est-ce que vous pouvez dire aux
sénateurs de la ligne que vous allez
fixer au gouvernement de ce que vous
retiendrez des amendements votés ici à
la Chambre haute et de ce que vous allez
écarter ben d'abord je dois dire qu'il y
a beaucoup de points de converggenence
sur l'étalement de la suppression de la
CE CVAE malus automobile crédit d'impôt
industrie verte on a beaucoup de
dispositifs qui sont très convergents et
qui sont validés par les sénateurs c'est
une bonne nouvelle on a des désaccords
ils ont créé une quinzain de niche
fiscal des milliards d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires non prévu ce que je ne
manque pas dez d'ailleurs pour l'instant
les dépenses ou les les gain demain
demain je ferai la synthèse mais mais il
y en a et donc je je pense que c'est
quelques sujets de désaccord après voilà
le le dialogue est de qualité mais je je
note qu'il valide quand même beaucoup
des grandes orientations de ce PLF ce
que l'on comprend aussi c'est que le
contexte du 493 vient un peu bousculer
les habitudes aussi du Parlement parce
qu'il a énormément d'amendements en plus
par rapport aux autres années c'est
parce que les députés n'ont pas pu du
tout aller au fond du texte ça aussi on
voit que le 493 vient déstabiliser
l'examen du du projet de loi de
financement projet de loi de finance ben
je vous confirme qu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup d'amendements beaucoup plus que
les que les autres années mais tout est
discuté je crois qu'on a un dialogue de
qualité 4 on aura on ira au bout de
cette discussion qui met en avant
effectivement comme je vous disais des
points de convergence et puis des points
de divergence parmi les mesures qui font
débat le Sénat a supprimé le bouclier
tarifaire pour l'électricité des ménages
les plus aisé le Sénat qui a voté la fin
du bouclier afin d'introduire des
mesures ciblées en faveur des ménages
les plus modestes vous étiez contre
cette modification de la chambre haute
pourquoi parce que il faut sortir
progressivement des boucliers baisse des
prix de l'énergie qui coûte très cher
pour les finances publiques on l'a
annoncé on a pris un engagement devant
les Français les prix de l'électricité
n'augmenteront pas plus de 10 % or
l'amendement porté par la majorité
sénatoriale c'est une augmentation des
prix de 20 % des févriers avec un chèque
un chèque mais à la fin on sait très
bien comment ça se passe avec leschèc
c'est la classe moyenne qui paye donc on
préfère moins d'augmentation de
prixélectricité respecter notre
engagement comme on a pu l'annoncer avec
Bruno Le Maire et juste une dernière
question parce que vous devez retourner
en séance mais Bruno Le Maire avait dit
qu'il était favorable à cette fin de
bouclier lors de la discussion générale
en disant effectivement qu'il y avait
ces 10 % qui ne devaient pas être
dépassé mais comment est-ce qu'on peut
comprendre ce changement de pied en une
semaine c'est pas un changement de pied
je pense qu'on est d'accord sur le fait
que il faut sortir progressivement du
bouclier on est pas d'accord sur la
méthode on ne veut pas que les prix
augmentent de plus de 10 % sans faire de
chèque la majorité sénatoriale et au là
d'ailleurs on souhaitait augmenter les
prix de l'électricité de 20 % avec un
chèque c'est plutôt une différence de
méthode que une divergence sur
l'objectif que l'on
poursuit